foreign
we're going to go to GT in Roanoke
Virginia to start this hour hi GT how
are you
hello I'm I'm all right a little a
little nervous and a little concerned
after checking my credit statement the
other day okay what's up
well I've got over 500 000 in debt and
um I'm getting ready to sell a house but
I just don't know what to do with the
money and I'm worried I made a mistake
okay five hundred thousand dollars in
debt on what
um thirty thousand dollars in truck uh
thirty five thousand on land at the lake
135 000 on the house that we're getting
ready to sell and 350 000 on the house
we just bought
okay and what's your household income
uh 160 to 180 depending on overtime okay
all right
yeah I would encourage you to separate
out the debt when you're kind of looking
at it because that is overwhelming when
you're having all of your the 350 is
your primary mortgage right
yes it is now we're moving into that one
within the month tell us a little bit
about the house you're about to sell
with the 135 that you mentioned how much
Equity is in that house
uh we've got it under contract for 260.
okay so what did you you've already
closed on the houses 350 that's your
main house right and that's your old
house right
the 350 is the one that we closed on
that we're moving into the other one
this whole house yes how much did you
put down we haven't closed
the 350.
uh none
but you're sort of uh
go ahead go ahead how did you do that
um it was a situation where it was about
to be foreclosed on and it was a great
deal it's probably worth five five fifty
and
um we just we the foreclosing Bank
wouldn't allow us to make a contingent
on selling our own home right and so you
just went got a bank loan
yes okay is that is the 350 now on a
permanent mortgage or is it still a bank
loan
permanent okay all right so you're set
up then the other house is sold when you
sell it you've got the money to pay off
the truck
and uh the other 35 000 right
yes and you'll be debt free other than
your home
yes okay where's the overwhelm part
uh just seeing half a million dollars in
debt I've never had that much before in
my life okay
so you're doing all this two-step and
you just didn't look at how many
different squares you were stepping on
yeah I guess so yeah and but now once
you finish the dance
it's not overwhelming anymore really
no no I guess not I mean you got 350 000
household house payment that's it
you've got
um another sixty thousand dollars laying
in your checking account that we need to
set some aside for your rainy day funds
your emergency fund let's call that
thirty five thousand that gives you 30
000 to put on some other stuff
um maybe get your retirement and your
kids college started with some of that
um and so the the end of the end of the
story turns out the the wake-up call and
the lesson to be learned it sounds like
is that
the way you went at this left you more
vulnerable than you like to be and I
would agree with you
yeah yeah because there was a moment
here
and we're kind of still sitting in it at
this moment until this house closes the
first house closes there's a moment here
where you're 550 000 in debt and if it
went sideways you'd be messed up
yeah like if the market froze up and you
couldn't sell that other house you'd be
up a Creek right now
yeah yeah I would and so the good news
is it sounds like you're going to get
out by the hair of your chinny chin chin
and end up in actually a good place but
the good news is it scared you enough to
make you concentrate more next time you
were faced with a similar
opportunity to hide the pee under a
shell
yeah
is that am I missing something
no no you're spot on I just like I said
you know once the numbers hit me it it
scared me and I was like what if
something goes wrong good and remember
that feeling yeah and so next time you
go I you know because I don't enter I
used to do stuff like that all the time
and and until like took my dad gum head
off and I'm you know walking around you
know like a Halloween costume or
something looking for my head it was
gone it just knocked it off and I'm like
geez man my whole life got turned upside
down here I just about I lost everything
I just about lost my marriage I lost
about it destroyed my whole freaking
world and so I don't ever I don't even
go close to that stuff anymore and so
that can be your lesson like I kind of
overstepped here
you know I I like I was walking along
the edge of the cliff and the Rocks were
falling off and I acted like they
weren't and I was singing and whistling
a tune and and I made it back like safe
but I'm not going to take that path
again I don't like being that close to
the edge and that's a good lesson so
just learn the lessons GT that's all I
would tell you yeah and then just use
that the lessons you've learned to
continue forward being responsible with
your finances stay away from the edge of
the dadgum cliff right exactly you know
that's really what it does come down to
so very very good question and
um so it's a good example and you know
his emotion came up and caught him but
if this had gone sideways and but now
that it's turned out it's really going
to leave him in a very good place a very
reasonable place he's debt-free
everything but his house 350 000
mortgage with 180 000 income that's not
out of line this is all very doable okay
he ends up in a good place but this is
an example of when he started this
process he doesn't know that's going to
turn out and that's what caught him and
took his breath away
most people don't even bother to have
their breath taken away they just go oh
that's what I planned and that's what
happened here's the debt only works or
buying two houses at one time only works
or doing anything only works when it
works
and most of the time life doesn't work
exactly the way you had it planned
and so that's when it gets your dad gum
head taken off and that's where you get
to experience the borrower is slave to
the lender and a foolish man devours all
he has and um In The House of the wise
are stores of choice food and oil and
these Bible verses that talk about
living on lesson you make having an
emergency fund having a plan and not
being in debt and
that you know that plan works in good
times and in bad times and so uh we had
a call in an earlier hour today where I
told a guy do not buy the second house
until the first one is sold remember
that same same scenario here because you
can get caught now good news is GT got
out I'm happy for him happy he didn't
learn the lesson except put his stomach
in his throat without having to learn
the lesson you know that's good that's
good I'm happy that there's no harm no
foul uh I don't wish bad things on
people what I try to do is help you
avoid setting yourself up where bad
things can get you don't let them get
you